hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university
videos tutorials then please visit the
support move section on move university
comm thank you and enjoy previously
we've talked about triglycerides or try
peso glycerols and their structures and
triglycerides triglycerol just mean the
same thing we know that this thing has a
glycerol backbone which we can see kind
of right here let's get that glycerol
backbone and it's got these three these
three acyl portions attached via ester
linkages right
those are acyl groups so we talked about
why triglycerides or try sub withdrawals
are important we said primarily that
they are an energy storage form so this
Troy glycerol is are the primary way
that our cells store energy and they
were also important for insulation which
help keep animals warm it's especially
important for animals who hibernate
during in cold environments like polar
bears for instance I think was the
example we used before so the question
is how do we make triglycerides how does
our body cells make them the first thing
that we're going to do is we're going to
start with a molecule called glycerol
3-phosphate what that's going to do is
that's going to give us basically our
glycerol backbone so we're starting off
by making that backbone and getting it
ready to go and what we're going to then
follow up by doing is we're going to
make a molecule that's called its
precursor it's often referred to as its
precursor that's going to be called
phosphated eight phosphide to date
alright so let's see how this works so
if we start right here at glycerol
3-phosphate of course it's numbered that
way because we've got carbons 1 2 & 3
here this is basically glycerol except
at the third carbon we've got a
phosphate group okay what we're going to
do here is basically we're going to take
an ACO Co a which is an activated fatty
acid we're going to add it to this
glycerol phosphate or the Swiss well
three phosphate and we're going to get
lie sofas for today
which basically just takes the acyl
group portion of the say so go away and
attaches it to carbon number one and
that is done by an enzyme called an acyl
transferase okay and once we have that
the second step to that's going to
follow up is basically we're going to
take another a soak away which could be
different and we're going to attach that
at the at the second carbon to get FASTA
today and that's again it's the same
exact process and it's going to be
catalyzed by an acyl transferase in both
cases a coenzyme a falls off now a
question that might come up is how do we
get this a soak away where does it come
from
this is an activated fatty acid so it
came from a fatty acid came from a fatty
acid so how did we get this a soak away
well if you recall from fatty acid
activation this was done by basically by
an enzyme called a sylco a synthetase
and the things that we invested it
required the equivalent of two ATP's and
also we have to add to add that coenzyme
a so here we're going to invest the
coenzyme a we add the ATP and off comes
an a MP and two or a pyrophosphate which
is eventually cleaved into two phosphate
groups but that's using the equivalent
of two ATP so that's how we get that and
that's going to give you this acyl Co a
and this isoka way comes about in the
same way it just has a different R group
portion all right so we have a different
fatty acid giving us this a SoCo a and
one thing to note is that this this
first a so Co a is usually usually
saturated while this one is usually
unsaturated
so that's how we get phosphate a date
which is a precursor to our triglyceride
that we'd mentioned earlier now before
we discuss further details about how we
go from class of today's would be actual
triglyceride what I want to ask is where
did this plus roll phosphate come from
or this quiz for all three phosphate
specifically come from so it could have
come from two places it could have come
from glycerol which of course is
glycerol 3-phosphate with no phosphates
could have come from glycerol and
basically what we could have done is
used an enzyme called withdraw kinase if
you recall kinase azar enzymes that add
phosphates of things these and these
phosphates come from ATP or gtv so here
we invest in ATP and it should make
sense in all these cases where we're
investing energy here because if this
whole process is meant to store energy
in the form of triglycerides it makes
sense that we're able to invest energy
here invest energy here in these steps
that that is that is okay because we
would store energy when we have enough
of it or more than enough of it so we
could have come from glycerol had a
glycerol kinase to give Qwest all three
phosphate or we could have started with
a different molecule you could have
started with this molecule here which is
dihydroxyacetone phosphate abbreviated
as d HAP and you can see the difference
between these two molecules is that
carbon number two carbons 1 & 3 we've
got the same exact situation going on
but a carbon to D HAP has this little
ketone
whereas this relative phosphate has an
alcohol so what happens here is there
was a reduction and this is catalyzed by
a dehydrogenase called glycerol
3-phosphate dehydrogenase and if we have
a reduction occurring then we would
expect to see a reducing agent and the
reducing agent here is NADH that's going
to be oxidized to nad plus while D AB is
reduced to its relative phosphate
another question is where could this I
hydroxy acetone phosphate have come from
where have we seen it before really is
kind of the question I'm getting at and
I'll let you think about it before I
actually say the answer if you like two
seconds - it's from glycolysis or
gluconeogenesis so I call this means
that this these carbons came from
glucose and again that should also make
a little bit of sense because if we're
storing energy especially if we consume
a lot of carbs and we have too much
carbohydrate energy for us to use
immediately and let's say we store some
of it as glycogen we still have some
more left we might want to store it as
fat right in triglycerides so it would
make sense that some of the carbons from
this glucose would contribute to making
the backbone of these triglycerides okay
so hopefully that all makes sense but
now the key here is that we've created
fossa today right this is the precursor
that we mentioned earlier and so let's
see what happens to this once we have
that precursor phosphatase this thing
can actually it's actually a precursor
that's common to both the production of
triglycerides and to
glycerophospholipids so you see her up
up top here we've got this
glycerophospholipid flatspin today is a
glycerophospholipid it's the simplest
one right it's also called da G 3
phosphate da G stands for diacylglycerol
two acyl groups glycerol and then three
phosphate here so this thing can be
converted into glycerol fought into a
glycerophospholipid by basically just
adding some alcohol to be to sort of
complete the polar head group here so up
here this step here is the addition of a
polar head group and more details will
be on that later that's not really what
this video is about we'll talk more
about the glycerophospholipids synthesis
later but I did want to mention is that
possible today is a precursor that's
common to both pathways to produce +4
phospholipids and to triglycerides which
we're talking about in this video
so FASTA today basically what we need to
do is you need to get rid of this
phosphate group and replace it with an
acyl group right to give us our
triglyceride so the first thing that we
actually do is that as FASTA today we'll
have to get rid of this phosphate via
hydrolysis reaction so this is
hydrolyzed off by water
and the enzyme that catalyzes that is a
phosphatase and it specifically
phosphatidic acid phosphatase so
phosphatase is basically phosphatidic
acid the difference is that phosphor
today is when it has it's when it's
deprotonated so faucet of gases would
have this this phosphate group
protonated that's the only difference
but the enzyme name still acts or the
enzyme instance should make sense acting
on the conjugate base form of the
molecule named
phosphatidic acid so basically we're
just cutting off this phosphate group
that's well that leaves and we get
diacylglycerol or d AG right just
glycerol with two acyl groups once we
have that we have an activated a so co a
that we can just add on to give us a
triglyceride and you might have guessed
already what the name of the enzyme
would be that gives us a strike bus ride
or catalyzes the specific reaction it's
just another racial transfer race we're
just taking this acyl group tacking it
on giving us our product and then again
this acyl group where'd it come from
from the activation of a fatty acid it
could potentially come from from fatty
acid synthesis as well but I mean I just
mentioned this here to discuss the idea
of investing ATP as a potentially
occurring what we're trying to store
energy so once we do that we have our
final product here we have this
triglyceride this is our final product
now a question is how you know where it
is this all happen right where which
organs is this occurring and there are
two primarily this all this will occur
in the liver and I know that just saying
that might work some people or it might
confuse some people but um from what
I've read most most of the time I see
that it is mentioned that the liver is
the primary location for which
triglycerides occurs the other place is
in the adipose tissue where the
triglycerides are stored
but there are some scarlet scholarly
articles that I've come across that
mentioned
adipose tissues actually the primary
location for which this process occurs
and I'm not entirely certain but from
what I can tell most most things that
I've read say the liver is the primary
location where it occurs so that might
be a you know a situation to discuss if
you're taking a course and this is a
gray area definitely talk to your
professor and TAS things like that okay
see kind of what they think and how they
feel about this particular question
furthermore though the organelle in the
cells where this would actually occur is
the organelle that does lipid synthesis
right triglycerides are lipids so the
organelle that this would occur in would
be the smooth endoplasmic reticulum the
smooth ER now a really important
question is that once these
triglycerides are made assuming
especially if they're made in the liver
if that's the primary primary location
where these things are made how do these
triglycerides get from the liver to the
adipose tissue right because adipose
tissue is sort of where these
triglycerides are primarily stored how
does it get from the liver all the way
over there well things get to and from
organs and tissues by means of
bloodstream and there are these little
proteins called lipoproteins lipoprotein
particles that basically carry lipids
from place to place in our bodies
through our bloodstream talk more about
that later but hopefully that kind of
wraps up triglycerides it's just really
well hope that video was helpful thank
you for watching thanks for watching
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and be sure to share the video with
anyone who you think might find helpful
thanks and happy studying